the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
welcome back today we are going to talk
about Forks so I think you guys have had
a guest lecture last week right from
allene Temescal who talked about his
project Katina and one of the really
interesting things about Katina is that
he's trying to prevent a server from
equivocating so he's trying to keep a
server from being able to say one answer
to some people and another answer to
another another person that's kind of
the goal of this whole blockchain thing
but there's actually something that that
really complex that happens when when we
start to change what's happening in the
network and we start to change the
software that's happening in the network
and so this lecture is going to be about
forks and I want you guys to feel free
to raise your hands and ask questions
during class because this stuff is is
actually kind of non-intuitive sometimes
so a blockchain right is a chain of
blocks which have previous hash pointers
inside of them so question can a block
point to two previous blocks at the same
time anybody know the answer this
question know exactly that is the whole
point there is exactly one spot in the
block header for a previous hash block
and so a block can only point to one
previous block a single block cannot
point to two previous blocks however can
this point happen can two different
blocks going to the same previous block
header yes yes and this happens all the
time now part of the reason that this
happens all the time is because the way
that blocks are found in the Bitcoin
network is completely probabilistic
there are many people who are trying to
find the next block at the same time and
it's entirely possible that two
different miners will get lucky in a
time period that is within the time it
takes for a block to get gossiped around
the network and so totally two people
can find the same block at the same time
this is actually what's known as a fork
and you can kind of see why we have a
four
in the chain right here okay um you know
what does it really mean when there's a
fork in the chain I just told you that
this is something that happens all the
time and you know these cryptocurrency
networks seem to keep running they seem
to be keep going
so perhaps it's not as bad as as it
seems even though it seems to be
violating one of the major tenets of
what a blockchain is well it's kind of
bad actually because when you have these
two blocks here is there anything that
makes one the right blockchain over the
other blockchain just sort of like you
know if this is one blockchain right
here and this is another blockchain
right there you know how is one supposed
to distinguish between this yeah the one
with the most work okay that's a great
sort of way of thinking about it yeah
what if they have similar amounts of
proof of work than what the one that's
accepted by the majority of network how
do we know which one is accepted by the
majority of the network it gets extended
okay great
so that that's a really good way of
looking at it before we go into what
that means do people understand why if
this state were to persist it would be a
really bad situation one thing that we
could have given that there's two blocks
what that really means is that we have
two versions of history we have two
versions of the ledger if these two
things are not the same different coins
might be spent on one side of the fork
versus on the other side of the fork in
fact the same coin might be spent to two
different people on either sides of
these Forks right and so over here Alice
might be spending her coin to Bob over
here Alice might be spending that same
coin and remember coins can only be
spent once even if Alice has other coins
she specifies which coin she's spending
Alice might spend that coin over to
Carol and so Bob sees this he thinks he
got paid if Carol sees this she thinks
she got paid and we violated one of the
fundamental tenants of the blockchain
which is not to double spend coins you
can't create money out of nowhere if
these two things would persist if we
don't resolve this fork somehow
then we literally have two different
versions of the same currency this is
kind of as though I took the money in my
pocket my dollar bill and i xeroxed
them all and managed to convince some
people that the xerox was also real this
is the exact same thing is what's
happening when when you have these two
things persist okay so how do we fix it
well which which is the right one right
and just given what I've shown you right
here it is not clear which is the right
one and like I also said this happens
all the time in the Bitcoin network
because the Bitcoin network is
probabilistic so the way that people
figure out which one is the right one is
they wait they wait and see which side
gets extended and by the nature of
probability one side is going to
eventually win out and get extended more
often than the other side it's very
unlikely for two forks to randomly sort
of probabilistically exist at roughly
the same weight for the same amount of
time for very long now as someone said
you might look at this how do you
distinguish between these two things
there is this common idea that in
blockchains we take the longest chain
longest is a little bit misleading
actually it's not the longest chain it's
the heaviest work chain so we pick the
chain that has the most proof of work on
it even if that happens to have a
smaller number of blocks usually that's
not the case that's not what happens the
reason for that does anyone know why we
take the heaviest chain instead of the
longest chain
right so it's not very easy to do this
but over time someone could slowly
decrease difficulty level and then
create a nice really long chain with
many low difficulty blocks and then say
hey I've got the longest chain I have
the most number of blocks despite the
fact that your chain has more proof of
work on it you should all take my chain
and they could do that with less than a
majority of the hash power now this is
not an easy attack to do but it is a
possible attack and so that's why we
take the heaviest chain which represents
the most hash power in the system the
majority of the system so Forks happen
all the time
Forks are normal the way that people who
see Forks decide which side of the fork
to use is they check and see which one
has the most proof-of-work the heaviest
proof-of-work now one thing that's kind
of cool is as you probably learned about
two classes ago even SPV nodes even even
clients can tell which chain has the
most proof of work simply by looking at
the headers the block headers they can
see what the difficulty is and they can
measure for themselves which side of the
chain has the most proof report they
don't even need all of the chain so this
is a nice property of light clients is
that they can download all of the block
headers and immediately tell which side
of a fork has the most proof of work
great we call the block that ends up so
what do we do with this block does
anyone know what actually happens with
this block anybody
okay so this block is basically
abandoned this block is just left it
exists it points into the chain that's
great in Bitcoin in particular it's
meaningless it doesn't mean anything
every transaction that was in that block
is not considered to have happened so
those transactions need to be replayed
on the chain that ends up being the
longest chain and this happens like I
said all the time we call that block an
orphan because it doesn't have anyone
it's kind of the wrong way around I mean
I think of this as a child but whatever
this you know block doesn't have a
parent but we call those blocks orphans
and again remember we pick the side of
the chain that ends up having the most
proof of work now we draw like these
figures in two different ways sometimes
we draw the figures like this like
there's this blockchain that exists out
there that you know is written down and
that everyone is sort of looking at
there's one blockchain but this is a
logical representation in reality there
are many many many different block
chains in fact every node in the system
has its own version of the blockchain
and it's what those nodes are doing
together that ends up deciding what the
blockchain actually is so if these are
nodes that are running the Bitcoin
protocol and when I say nodes what's the
difference between a minor and a node
yes no question sections but miners push
great blocks so miners actually create
blocks in the system miners have right
access to the blockchain they actually
produce new blocks there's a people
think a lot about you know about what
the miners are and what the miners can
do and there's a lot of game theory
thinking about the miners and Oh what if
happened what if they colluded with the
hash power does this and sometimes we
forget that nodes in the Bitcoin network
are actually incredibly important too
because it's the nodes in the Bitcoin
network they're not creating blocks and
to be clear someone could be a miner and
a node at the same time so they're not
you know they're distinct roles but they
the same entity could certainly run a
node and be a minor but nodes are doing
something really important as well which
is they're reading all of the blocks and
they're deciding which side of a fork to
take and which blocks to accept and
which blocks not to accept so let's say
that these are all Bitcoin nodes okay
and this is what the blockchain looks
like right now and we've use this figure
multiple times every block has a
previous hash which acts as a pointer to
the previous block okay
every block has a set of transactions
and every block has a nonce such such
that when you take the hash of the block
header you end up with something that
has a sufficient number of leading zeros
it has valid proof of work okay
great so let's say that this is the
state of the system right now and then
we see this new block come along so what
happens here is that a miner has
produced this block and has sent it out
over the Bitcoin network they've sort of
gossipping the block around the Bitcoin
network and so every one of these nodes
hopefully will eventually if they're
well connected will see this block
they're gonna see the block at different
times and they're each gonna make an
independent decision about the block
okay so every node is going to decide
when it sees this block what to do with
it
okay and there's basically two things
that can do with it one it can add it to
its own local version
of the blockchain and number two it can
reject it
does everyone see why that is so sure
every note is maintaining this local
copy of a blockchain there is no single
global copy that everyone is referring
to physically there's no single database
running the blockchain every node has
its own local copy of the blockchain
every node is making its own local
decisions about whether or not a block
is valid and about whether or not it's
going to add that block to its own local
copy of its blockchain so the way that
the node decides this is that it it has
a set of validation rules so it has its
own set of rules which are specified by
the Bitcoin protocol and it checks that
block against its set of validation
rules so every node every Bitcoin note
is constantly validating constantly
validating blocks here are just some of
the validation rules and we've talked
about a lot of these sort of off and on
during the class so first of all there's
a max block size a block hat and the way
that this works is if at any point you
fail one of these validation rules you
reject the block okay
so first the block has to be smaller
than this variable max block size at the
moment max block size is set to one
megabyte every single transaction in the
block also has to be valid and what does
that mean well it needs to be formatted
a certain way and it also means that
when we concatenate the script pub key
and the script sig together and then run
that through the interpreter to evaluate
the script on the stack it ends up
returning true and if at any point any
transaction and not just any transaction
any input in any transaction does not
satisfy this we reject the entire block
we make sure that another thing that
that each transaction needs to satisfies
if if it's valid is that the if the
transaction specifies an end lock time
then that end lock time needs
be greater than whatever specified in
the transaction that transaction is now
is now far enough in the future that it
can be satisfied the block as a whole
needs to have valid proof of work so it
needs to have a naught such that when
you have the block header you end up
with a hash that has a certain number of
leading zeros and what's really
interesting is a protocol also specifies
exactly how many leading zeros there
need to be depending upon how many
leading zeros there have been in blocks
in the past there cannot be any double
spends so given the version of the block
chain that I as a node have this better
not be double spending any outputs there
are some rules around what the block can
have is it's timestamp it cannot be more
than if I see a block that has a
timestamp that's more at more than two
hours in the future from my own time
snap I will reject it and if it isn't I
don't know after some point that's the
median of the previous blocks timestamps
then I'll also reject it and of course
the block needs to actually point to a
block that I've seen before and as a
note I will keep around blocks which
have a previous hash pointer that I
don't know about but I'm not gonna keep
them around forever because that's a
potential dose attack and in order for
me to actually insert this block into my
version of a block chain I need to know
which block to put it after note also
note what's not on here is that it needs
to be the only block pointing to a
previous block I'll keep around multiple
blocks at the same level until I have
some sense of which one's going to win
out because of the probabilistic nature
of maybe this block I'm seeing is not
going to end up being part of the block
chain maybe it's going to be an orphan
so these rules these validation rules
are what are called consensus critical
rules in the Bitcoin network and what
that means is that if you want to tweak
these rules
if you want to change them then you may
end up changing which blocks nodes will
accept and which blocks nodes won't
accept now something that's kind of
interesting to note here is that the
entire script interpreter in Bitcoin is
consensus critical yes yes it can
yes so you can definitely have a block
so let's that's a great question
actually so let's say that we had a
block that was half a megabyte
what would nodes do what do you think
that's true what wouldn't what would you
as a node do if you're running the
Bitcoin protocol is it exists right
today and has the following set of rules
and I hand you a block that's half a
megabyte what would you do you would say
ok exactly because the rule that I
specified here just says the block has
to be less than one megabyte it didn't
say it has to be greater than anything
and is half a megabyte less than one
megabyte yes so you're gonna pass the
checks and you're going to accept the
block
sure so the question is should miners
remove transactions from a block or
perhaps not put transactions in a block
because it seems like they could process
a small block faster than a large block
right so that is very true miners if
they if there are fewer transactions
they have fewer things to verify so they
can check and see if the block is valid
faster however the fewer transactions
the fewer the transaction fees and so
the less the miner will earn from the
block yes yeah verifying right so so
verifying transactions is very it's not
as nowhere near as CPU intensive as it
is to actually produce the proof that
find the nonce and produce the proof of
work
however miners should verify
transactions before even starting that
process and so if a miner didn't verify
transactions they would get a head start
on the proof of work process so so
there's that sort of balance and in fact
and I think we've talked about this in
this class before there have been times
in history where things have happened
that have shown that miners actually
haven't been verifying blocks little
dozers mine on whatever it's caused some
problems and they ended up losing a lot
of money because they should have been
verifying blocks great so these rules
are what are called consensus critical
they are the rules that each node
independently uses to decide whether or
not they're going to accept a block yes
no I am NOT talking about sPB's when I
talk about notes I'm I'm actually
talking about full notes so I'm talking
about nodes that are hold that are
holding onto the entire Bitcoin
blockchain that are looking at every
block every transaction okay a minor
yeah they're distinct roles so a minor
is running this proof-of-work
algorithm to try to find to produce
blocks right a full node does not write
blocks it doesn't create new blocks it
receives blocks and then validates them
and or not and adds them to its local
copy of the blockchain a minor might
also be running a full node yes for the
reasons we were talking about before I'm
sorry
okay so let's go back to this image
right here these nodes are all running
some version of the software they see
this transaction and they say yes this
looks like a valid transaction to me and
note that they have to eval or sorry
block they look at this block yes this
looks like a valid block to me and note
that they kind of have to evaluate that
block with respect to all of the other
blocks that it's seen no double spends
all of the scripts eggs and script pub
keys work out correctly it's the right
size etc etc and then once it's decided
that that's all okay each node will
independently make the same decision to
add that block to its block team so you
can see here that like determinism is
actually really important it can't be
the case that like there's any
randomness in this process it can't be
the case that looks sort of randomly
depending on the time of day one node
will decide this is a valid black one
notice it'll decide it's not a valid box
that's like not the greatest situation
to have
happen we want this to be as
deterministic as possible we want them
to all independently arrive at the same
decision great so this is how validation
works this is what nodes do major
problem though sometimes we need to
change the validation rules sometimes we
need to upgrade the software right
I mean software is not a static thing
the software that these nodes are
running you know there's gonna be bugs
there might be security vulnerabilities
we might want to add new features and so
we're going to want to change the
validation rules it's pretty much
inevitable and yet given the nature of
the system
we can't upgrade every single node at
the same time so I think a useful
analogy here something to think about is
actually browsers so web browsers right
now a lot of people run Chrome but not
everyone runs chrome and chrome actually
has auto update where it will push
changes to your browser Google will
automatically upgrade you but the way
the browsers you used to work is that
you didn't always have auto update or it
would bother you and ask you if you were
ok with auto updating before and people
would say I don't want to deal with this
right now I'm in the middle of something
I don't to update my browser and have to
restart the whole thing and so what
would end up happening is that you'd
have significant numbers of people on
very different versions of browsers and
this was kind of a disaster for the
internet because people who are
developing websites could not sort of
they wouldn't have any confidence that
the majority of their users are like a
significant majority of their users had
upgraded to the new features so they had
to support all these old versions of
browsers and it was a nightmare so
that's what we're dealing with here in
crypto currencies except it's even worse
so you definitely cannot guarantee that
everyone will upgrade their software at
the same time you can't guarantee that
everyone will even upgrade ever and so
the designers of the software when you
want to create a new version of software
you have to think really really
carefully about it so let's say that
we're in this situation right here where
these three nodes are running the one of
the software the developers have worked
out v2 v2 has some interesting new
features which slightly changed the
validation rules about what a node
running v2 will consider valid or
invalid okay so now when we see this new
block right and we ask the question is
this block valid these nodes might make
different decisions in particular maybe
the old nodes will think it's valid
great passes all the validation rules I
will append this block to my blockchain
and the new node will not think it's
valid and will say Oh garbage block
fantastic I will not append this block
to my blockchain and what and we end up
with when this happens is we have two
different versions of history the nodes
are running the old version of the
software think that there are four
blocks in the blockchain the nodes that
are running the new version of the
software have decided that that block is
invalid and they only have three blocks
in the blockchain so what does this mean
first of all is this like the situation
we saw before where if we just wait for
enough proof of work this will sort
itself out what do you guys think I'm
seeing some people shaking their heads
and yes this situation is different than
the situation we saw before because the
situation we saw before all the nodes
still had the same validation rules they
just hadn't seen they just saw the
blocks in different orders or you know
things just you know they got online
later whatever all of that can be
resolved by looking at the proof of work
sometimes when this happens sometimes
when nodes are actually running
different versions of validation
software things can be resolved by just
looking at proof of work but quite often
actually they can't and so in this
situation what might happen is on
another block comes along so this is a
different block than this one right and
this set of nodes might decide that this
is the next block in the blockchain
whereas the blue nodes
we'll never ever ever validate this
block okay they will never decide that
this block is valid given the version of
the software they are running they will
never switch to a blockchain that has
this block in it even if it has the most
proof of work so I think this is a
really important point and I think it
sort of fundamentally gets to why miners
don't actually have as much power in the
system as one might think that they do
and the reason for that is that the way
bitcoin is designed is that a node will
never accept a chain with a single
invalid transaction if according to its
set of rules a single transaction is
invalid it will completely ignore that
chain doesn't matter if it has the most
proof of work okay does that make sense
to everyone it's I mean it's kind of
intense it's kind of crazy right like
even if it has like mountains upon
mountains of proof of work it will
completely ignore that chain because
there's something invalid about it
so miners can you know mind what they
want but they better mind within the
validation rule set of the economic
majority of the nodes otherwise those
nodes are all gonna ignore whatever they
mine and their money's not gonna be
worth anything great so in this
situation we end up with two different
block chains and we actually end up with
something quite your reconcilable unless
we change the software again somehow and
what we've ended up with it that's
irreconcilable is we now have a block
over here and a block over here this
node will never accept a chain with this
block in it and so we've got two
different block chains so when this
happens we call it a fork now the word
fork can be used to mean many different
things in software for example you fork
a project on github right when you fork
up reject on github you might make
changes to it this is a little bit
different because of the linearity of
history here when a fork
happens in a cryptocurrency in
particular a sort of a fork that can't
easily be resolved that isn't just gonna
you know oh one side is more proof of
work okay great we're all gonna switch
to that other side when you have a fork
that can't be resolved that easily then
it's actually a pretty big deal because
like we were saying earlier we now have
two versions of history two different
versions of money it's like I took the
the dollar from my wallet and I
photocopied it and now there's two
dollars where there was only one so
maybe you like this kind of dollars
maybe you don't like that kind of
dollars we've basically taken this
entire network that all sort of agreed
on what this form of money was and we've
divided it into two so there's two
different kind of forts that people will
talk about mostly in this industry but
it's forking is actually much more
complicated than that there's like you
can't just talk about Forks as in so the
two different kinds of Forks are soft
Forks and hard Forks and I'm gonna
explain what soft work is versus a hard
fork but actually that delineation it's
it gets much more nuanced because
different things happen in a soft work
force is a hard fork depending upon who
is decided to adopt the rules
okay so soft work so a soft fork is a
fork which is backwards compatible okay
so we have some rule set okay
and under that rule set we produce
certain a certain okay you apply that
rule set to every single possible one
megabyte chunk of data and we're gonna
end up with some set of what are valid
blocks okay a soft fork is when you add
rules to the rule set such that the set
of valid blocks actually shrinks okay so
what does that mean we had a whole bunch
of rules before right blocks have to be
less than one megabyte transactions all
have to be valid it means that their
scripts certify like validate under the
certain script interpreter etc no
doubles fence let's take one of the
rules that's actually pretty simple
which is that blocks have to be less
than one megabyte
let's say that I changed that two blocks
have to be less than two megabytes is
that a soft fork oh wow there's some
actual dissent over this right okay so
someone who says no why is the answer no
right so remember valid blocks before
newly valid blocks fit inside of this
now someone who said yes at the software
quai do you think that's the software
right so it's actually not a soft fork
and the reason that it's not a soft fork
is because a block that is 1.75
megabytes
previously the old rule set was invalid
right new rule set it's valid but we
just said everything that's newly valid
has to fit inside what was used to be
valid so a soft fork is restricting the
set of valid things you can think of it
as expanding the set of rules that that
we that a block now has to comply with
so
a feature of this is that if you don't
upgrade so v1 is the old rule software
v2 is the new rule software if you don't
upgrade you will continue to see the new
blocks is valid and this is actually a
very nice property because remember what
happened over here we had this property
where the people on the blue side we're
just never ever going to accept one of
these block chains right and and if it
were the case that this were a soft fork
the old side would never ever well if
this case that this sorry if it were the
case that this weren't a soft work the
old nodes would never accept this new
stuff okay so soft works are really nice
because they're backwards compatible old
nodes will still see the new blocks as
valid they won't reject them if that
chain gets a ton of proof-of-work then
the old nodes will happily switch over
to that chain so what does that mean so
let's say that the black nodes are the
old rules and the blue nodes are the new
or new rules new rule blocks okay and
again we have to look at this from two
different perspectives there are the
people creating the box and there are
the people reading the blocks and
sometimes those are the same people
sometimes they're not okay so we're
looking at blocks here so these are
people who are creating the blocks in a
soft fork the miners who and again both
of these sets of people might upgrade or
not upgrade okay
so it's so we may have miners who are
following the old rules and miners who
were following the new rules then we
might have validating nodes or following
the old rules and validating nodes who
were following the new rules and this is
not even talking about SPV yet okay
we're just talking about miners and
we're talking about nodes so let's say
some of the miners upgrade to the new
rules but not all of the miners upgrade
to the new rules the miners who didn't
upgrade to the new rules are gonna
continue producing old rule blocks
they're gonna continue producing v1
version blocks but if the majority of
miners upgrade to the new rules remember
the new rule the new rule people have
new rules so
they have more restrictions on the set
of blocks that they will accept so they
might not see that block is valid so
they're never gonna accept that chain
because it has 'invalid things in it
once you've upgraded you might no longer
accept the old chain is valid and so
what's gonna end up happening is
something that looks very much like the
orphanage situation that was happening
before where if the majority of the hash
power switches over here this chain is
gonna keep growing bigger these guys
might keep trying to produce old-style
blocks but they just keep getting
orphaned off it's actually like very
much in their economic interest to hurry
up an upgrade so they're not wasting
hash power on orphan blocks are there
questions about softworks yes so our
software is also used for changing
software other than validation yes but
when we that's a great question our soft
forks also used for changing software
other than validation so we can
certainly upgrade more than just the
validation parts of the Bitcoin software
if it doesn't change the set of blocks
that would be accepted or not accepted
we don't even bother calling it a fork
so let's say that we wanted to change
something about the peer-to-peer network
and or the way that things are stored on
disk or something like that we would say
that a change like that if it didn't if
it didn't change the set of blocks that
would have been accepted or not accepted
if after the change a set of blocks
accepted or not accepted is the exact
same we don't call that a fork a change
that induces a fork it's only when the
set of blocks are accepted it wouldn't
be accepted are actually changed yes
great question how often do updates get
pushed on the network so bitcoins at
version ODOT 16 right now and no doubt
16 came out like a week or two ago and I
think it's sort of been on the order of
a couple months between different
versions of Bitcoin other
cryptocurrencies release more frequently
some release less frequently some do
forks very very regularly and wilcott
will tip will speak a little bit about
that but the software is pretty much
constantly getting updated oh yeah so so
in Bitcoin in particular Bitcoin does
not have an auto update function so in
order to run the new version of the
software you have to decide that you're
going to run the new version of the
software or there might be a way to
decide to turn auto update on I can't
remember but the point is is that they
try to leave it in their users hands yes
yeah
so okay how were versions created it's
actually very similar to any other
software project where the people who
work on the software project get
together and decide which pull requests
are going to be part of the new versions
so yes at some point they're just like
new version release definitely releases
updated versions so that's a that's a
great question I think not every version
has a soft work in it but if there is a
soft work it will definitely be a new
version yes it's not a blue block so so
so you're going you're you're talking
about you're talking about here right so
so okay so the nodes are running
different software right and then a
block comes along that these ideally yes
the block would have a version number in
it that specifies which version of the
software it is and this is a very useful
field in the block header but that
that's not really you know so what it
has a different version sorry higher
than like that I don't do it so what do
you mean I don't do it I mean you ignore
it
so that would be one way of running the
network which is if I ever see anything
that indicates that there's newer
software out there I just realize I'm
old and then I need to update I think
that Bitcoin simply made a different
design decision which was that older
nodes should still be able to be because
because think about nodes that never
that just were sort of set it and forget
it
they're out there running right I mean
one tenant that is absolutely true is
that users will not upgrade they will
not all upgrade it just
happen you will have old versions of
software running and given that you will
have old versions of software running I
think it's a question as to whether or
not those nodes should still be a part
of the network or whether you just want
to slice them off because they're not
running the latest version and I think
in Bitcoin they want those nodes to
still be a part of the network they want
people to be able to make the active
decision not to upgrade Tadgh actually I
think is still running
ODOT one three or some older version of
Bitcoin still works great
you can still validate transactions
totally fine okay so so we just talked
about soft Forks and I think the
important thing to remember about soft
works is that soft works are backwards
compatible we also talked about an
example of that is not a hard fork which
is if we decided that we wanted to allow
blocks that were less than two megabytes
instead of less than one megabyte and so
a 1.75 megabyte a block block appears
that is not a soft work what if we
changed rule to say that instead of only
accepting blocks that are less than one
megabyte we're only going to accept
blocks that are less than half a
megabyte is that a soft work or hard
fork that's a soft fork the reason that
that's a soft fork is because a block
that is less than half a megabyte was
also still less than one megabyte so
it's still valid under the old set of
rules okay so if the change made here
was now we want smaller blocks so we're
only gonna take blocks that are less
than half a megabyte that's fine oh you
know everyone will still see this chain
is valid this is still backwards
compatible just because your blocks are
300 kilobytes now doesn't mean that they
violate a rule
right so what happens to all the
previous stuff in my chain right now
ideally the way that the rules would be
would be set up the new rules is that
they would take effect sometime in the
future so you wouldn't apply those rules
retro actively to the things that you
already have put into the chain because
then you just throw away all history
right and that would be kind of a bummer
instead you say after this block we are
only going to accept blocks that are
less than half a megabyte great question
start doing that chain [ __ ] and what
happens when the majority versus
minority of different parts of the
ecosystem decide to adopt the change
versus not adopt attention okay but
first we're going to talk about hard
forks what is a hard fork a hard fork is
not backwards compatible and so a hard
fork is a fork where if this was the old
set of rules under the new set of rules
you actually accept more blocks than you
would have accepted before okay so just
to be clear under the new rules you
might produce a block which a node
running under the old rules will reject
this is not backwards compatible because
any chain that has this new type of
block in it will not be accepted by any
of the old nodes
full-stop doesn't matter uh
proof-of-work at all
okay so the thing with hard works is
that because they're not backwards
compatible they're a little crazier and
a little bit sort of harder to manage in
your network because if you do a hard
fork and not everyone upgrades you might
end up with two chains
possibly forever if we assume that those
nodes are not going to upgrade and let's
say they're not upgrading because
there's no one really maintaining them
then they're not going to upgrade in the
future and they're not going to upgrade
to a change that might fix what's going
on here they're just gonna keep doing
their old their old time thing then with
a hard fork these nodes are never gonna
accept the new blocks it doesn't matter
what the proof of work is on that
chamber so hard Forks versus soft works
hard Forks as I keep stressing or not
backwards compatible guess what a fork
can be a hard for you know soft work at
the same time yay super confusing
actually because you can both restrict
the set of rules and expand the set of
rules at the same time basically it
means it's a new overlapping but not
entirely inclusive or not inclusive set
of rules
we're very unfortunate in fact most
things shouldn't actually be both to
avoid some of the things that I'm gonna
show you in a minute yes for all the
useful purposes
it for all useful purposes it's not just
a hard fork um let me see if I can the
reason that it's not just a hard fork
this is something that requires a little
bit more thought it's not just a hard
fork
but I will think about how to explain
this and perhaps yeah
it is but he's asking isn't that just a
hard fork and it's not just a hard fork
because I think old nodes will do
something different okay so there's two
reasons why it might it's not just a
hard fork one is because of reorg so
different things will happen as the
majority of hash power starts to accept
or not accept the change whether or not
old nodes will switch over or not but if
it's about the heart and a soft work
they will never switch over but I think
the question is whether whether old
nodes can even still function so I think
you use combination one way to use
combination of hard and soft Forks is to
actually stop the old nodes from being
able to have blocks at all like you
design things in such a way that given a
majority of hash power moves over they
can even like they're just gonna end up
with nothing but this is a really good
question and we should go into more
detail on this and I will try to figure
out a way to get that to you guys
okay so who controls Forks yes sorry
okay the developers which I didn't even
write down as a note here okay do the
Bitcoin developers control Forks who
thinks yes okay who thinks no determines
whether or not a fork is going to go
through there's a Bitcoin developers who
are actually writing the software right
and who also have a lot of influence in
the system because presumably they
understand it really well if they're
writing software right so they can write
some software and decide that they want
to do a fork does that mean that the
fork is going to go through no certainly
not right
everyone can ignore them and there have
been situations in the past where
everyone ignored them for quite a long
time and argued about it and didn't push
a fork through
well miners
the ones who actually create the blocks
right are they the ones who control
forks I hear I see a very strong head
shake no why do you see why do you shake
it right now very true so as we saw
before there are there are times when
nodes will not accept a chain no matter
how much proof of work it has on it I
think it's a very common like
misunderstanding the nodes run their own
validation roles and so if I'm running a
node I can run whatever validation rules
I want and I can decide what chain is
the one that aligns with my interests
yes if you are 40 you are accepting new
blocks exactly so there's certainly
certainly like incentives in many
different directions if all the miners
decided to go to one side well then I'm
a full node with my set of validation
rules who has no new blocks great like
you know what am I gonna do how am I
gonna make transactions how am I gonna
spend my money also you know let's say
all the miners don't go to one side but
you know most of them do and most of the
nodes go to the other side then what am
I gonna do who's gonna listen to me
who's gonna trade with me who's gonna
who's gonna take the coins on my side of
the fork so I guess that's just to say
that it's complicated it's there's the
developers there's the miners there's
nodes
there's the users who determine the
economic value of these tokens and which
side they think is more valuable or less
valuable and we've seen this happen with
lots of cryptocurrencies multiple times
and it's kind of exciting
so bitcoins forked multiple times and
every time it's forked so far it has
created a whole new version of the coin
so it's been like a pretty serious hard
fork and so now in addition to Bitcoin
is Bitcoin cash Bitcoin gold Bitcoin
diamonds
atheria m-- also has fort in aetherium
x' case they tried to take along
everyone with them and so the hard fork
was supposed to be an upgrade to
aetherium but some people decided they
didn't want to go along with it so
there's a theorem classic and there's a
theorem um both of them have value so
it's really unclear who controls Forks
so now let's talk about hash rate and
forks so nodes are pretty like okay
nodes what nodes will do is they have a
set of validation rules if a block
validates under their set of validation
rules they will accept it and they will
accept if all the blocks validate under
their validation rules they will accept
the chain that those blocks are on and
if there are two different chains where
all the blocks validate under their
validation rules they'll take the one
with a heaviest proof-of-work that's
what nodes do okay so heaviest proof of
work is clearly kind of important here
if both sides of a fork validate so if
both sides of a fork validate and we so
we have to think about this from the
perspective of minor sorry of nodes who
upgrade to the new software and nodes
who don't upgrade to the new software
okay so might be worth it to try to kind
of write this down a little bit
so we have the old role nodes and the
new rule nodes and let's just talk about
one kind of work for now now let's say
less than 50 percent of the miners
upgrade and let's say greater than 50
percent of the miners upgrade okay
so let's use this chart as we're kind of
trying to reason about what's gonna
happen in the ecosystem for softworks
and hard Forks okay so what happens if a
soft fork does not obtain more than 50
percent of the hash rate so we've got
the old rules right
we've got nodes some nodes have upgraded
some notes haven't upgraded less than 50
percent of the miners have upgraded so
the old rule chain is going to be longer
because they're gonna continue mining on
the old rules by the way sometimes they
don't ignore things with the new rules
sometimes they do it's very complicated
but let's just pretend right now that
they are ignoring things with the new
rules because they haven't upgraded and
they don't see that or sorry they would
see the new rules as valid but the
majority of the hashing power is over
here so what's going to happen yes
don't be some worse than your rule are
sub-blocks than the rules but the
majority right so it kind of depends on
it kind of depends on the soft fork so
it depends on what the new rule nodes
think of old blocks if they think that
old blocks are still all valid then
they're going to build upon old blocks
just fine because they think they're
valid if they think that old blocks are
no longer valid then they're gonna try
to do their own chain and but the
majority of the hashing power is with
the old side so they're just gonna get
reorg out yes so an example of this is
paint a script hash so or an example of
this is is taking what was an unused
opcode and now making it meaningful so
it just so happens that none of the old
rule nodes ever used the silly unused
opcode because they never used it
they never had any invalid uses of the
block code right of the opcode so the
new nodes will still accept old blocks
because none of them use this OP code
anyway but if they were to use the new
op code they and they use it as a no op
op code instead of what the new rules
are then it would be an invalid block
does that make sense
so you have to think really carefully
about how you are designing these
upgrades to your software you have to
think very carefully what will happen to
the old knows what happens a 50% of the
miners update this thing well under the
old rules was anyone actually using this
thing that we are now maintaining must
be used in a new way or pane of script
hash is a good example of this as well
PETA script hash technically looks like
you're just paying to a hash so all
nodes will see it in
say okay if you can produce a signature
that shows that this valid blah blah
blah whatever whatever that's fine but
nobody ever did that nobody ever did
that in a way that that was meaningful
under the new rules no one ever used it
so all the old all the old things will
still validate simply because no one
ever did anything there was under the
subset of the new rules sorry this is
very kind of complicated okay so what we
have here is that if old rule blocks are
still valid the soft work will get reorg
doubt okay so no wait no fork there no
no fork there you're just not really
going to end up with stuff in the
blockchain if old rule blocks are now
invalid then we're gonna end up with two
chains
do people see why this is because the
new rule people are not going to accept
in any chain that has an invalid thing
in it so there's now going to be two
they're not going to reorder
they're gonna continue and they are
gonna have their own chain and they're
gonna ignore all of the blocks on the
other chain which they deemed to be the
invalid chain yes no it's not a case of
Ikhwan cash it's actually the case for
something called a user activated soft
work which the Bitcoin community
threatened to do when the miners
wouldn't do a soft work they wanted them
to do they said fine you miners won't do
the soft work that we want you to do and
under sea normally people don't like
this situation so you don't want this to
happen
so normally soft works are written such
that if you don't get 95% of the miners
to sign on the software never activates
so that's the way that traditionally
software acts are done in the Bitcoin
ecosystem what does that mean it means
5.000 1% of the hash power can stop a
software from going through so usually
things are written in such a way that
you really want to guarantee this to
chain thing never happens we see hash
power is kind of voting
and if you can get 95% of the hash power
to agree with the software then only
will the software activate and the way
that miners do this is they signal in
their block headers that they are going
to adopt the soft work and then the soft
work is usually programmed in such a way
that it looks at some sliding window of
block headers to determine whether 95
percent of the hash power is decided
that they're going to go along with it
and it only activates once that's the
case so doing protocol upgrades is
really hard it's like not a trivial
matter you don't just like push some
code so so usually it's the case that
you want to wait for a significant
majority of the mining power to indicate
support for the soft fork and by the way
they can indicate support without
actually running the soft work this
happens all the time but you want to
wait for significant support from the
mining community before actually
activating the soft fork what happened
recently with with something called
segregated witness which we'll talk
about which was a soft work to Bitcoin
to introduce new functionality that the
miners opposed was the community
actually said forget it we are going to
start running the new rules we're going
to ignore you we don't care what the
majority of the hash power does we are
going to go ahead create this to chain
situation and follow the chain with the
new rules interestingly this actually
worked I think it was like 80 plus
percent of the hash power was not in
favor of the soft work and the users
managed to create this kind of they
taught where they forced everyone to go
along with what they wanted it's super
interesting yes they had no actual way
to vote it was it was entirely sort of
via Twitter but you know
you threaten a user active song actually
it's all the line is just say they'll do
it anyway yeah so this is one of the
major reasons and I think some of the
strongest evidence that minors have
nowhere near as much power as you
actually think they do in these
ecosystems certainly have power and part
of the power they have is to do what's
called an evil soft fork which I'm not
gonna talk about in this class but I
think we probably should talk about at
some point in time okay great
so let's see okay if the soft fork is
greater than 50% old rule blocks will
follow the new rule blocks automatically
so we get yes soft fork successful we do
not have to chains because these will
simply be orphaned and abandoned and in
fact there's actually pressure for the
minors to move over to the new rules so
that their blocks aren't abandoned yes
it depends so for the okay so question
is around difficulty and the number of
leading zero is required in the proof of
work that changes all the time there's a
formula which determines what that
number should be so no it doesn't
require fork but if you want to change
the formula that would be a fork
requiring more proof of work would be a
soft work requiring less proof of work
would be a hard fork okay okay now let's
talk about hard forks so what happens if
a hard fork doesn't obtain 50 percent of
the hash rate
it depends again it depends on if the
old rule blocks are still valid so we're
doing a hard fork we are changing the
set of valid box if blocks are still
valid under the old rules then we're
gonna end up with a situation like this
if old road blocks are still valid
according to the new rule nodes then the
numeral nodes will just follow along
okay so like basically no fork happening
here because the new rule nodes are
gonna produce blocks they're not going
to have enough of the hash power and so
you know they might they're not going to
be considered valid by the other set so
they're there you're they're gonna end
up following along with the old new old
rule nodes yes not if it's a combination
hard fork software so maybe I should
split this up into whether or not it's a
combination hard for a soft work or not
okay so what happens if a hard fork does
obtain greater than 50% of the hash rate
what's going to happen then
yes we're gonna end up with 2 Chainz
this is gonna have chain this is very
whatever the point is there's gonna be
an old chain and a new chain the old
nodes are never going to accept the new
nodes blocks and we're going to end up
with two chains forever and this has
happened multiple times are there
questions about hard Forks yes or the
ways for a hard fork to make life really
difficult for the smaller chain that is
a good question I think it depends so
there's like multiple ways to make life
difficult
I think what you're asking is not you
know what if the hard fork becomes more
popular and more people decide to move
over it and abandon the smaller chain
that's one way in which life could be
more difficult but another way that life
could be more difficult is if the hard
Forks somehow made the previous chain no
longer a productive chain to be on right
and I think that the primary way that
that would happen would not actually be
a hard fork but would be a combination
hard fork software but there is there
are definitely ways for miners to play
with hard Forks and softworks in such a
way that see this is actually kind of
ideal in some ways this is like okay we
disagree on what the rule should be I
want some new set of rules you don't
want some new set of rules fine let's
just split the ecosystem you guys go
your way we'll go I'll go my way we'll
have two different coins life will be
great right what's kind of not so nice
is when one side tries to coerce the
other side to go along which is kind of
what a greater than 50% soft fork is
you're kind of coercing the other side
to go along because there they have no
way of opting out
and there are ways that miners can make
the side of the chain with less hash
power basically useless this is totally
something miners can do people talk
about it occasionally just doesn't seem
like they've figured out that they can
do it or they haven't tried to do it I
don't know maybe they don't want to do
it I'm not sure it would be pretty
disruptive to the ecosystem okay so
question we've talked about what happens
here from the perspective of full nodes
and from the perspective of miners what
happens from the perspective of people
with wallets who might be running SPV
what do we think depends on what you
know they're connected to so one problem
with SBV is that they don't actually get
the blocks right so they don't actually
validate blocks all they validate is
proof-of-work some changes that make a
block invalid might show up in the
header but a lot of changes that might
make a block invalid or or new blocks
valid don't show up in the header so
given what we've learned about how SPV
works what happens when there's a fork
so let's go back and take a look at what
SPV wallets see right they see the block
headers you have to download all the
headers which includes the nonce for the
proof-of-work the merkel route for the
transaction time stamp stuff like that
they also get merkel paths for the
transactions that they've told the node
that you tick so they've told the node
they're interested in right so what
would happen if there were a software or
hard fork what would happen to an SPV
client
they don't really have a say in the
situation
they aren't really participating in
validation they're not participating in
mining and they're kind of at the mercy
of whatever node that they are talking
to so and in fact if they try to talk to
multiple nodes they might get multiple
different answers and they don't really
know which answers the right answer and
I mean this could get really tricky and
complicated now I think probably it's
fair to say that the majority of the
Bitcoin ecosystem in terms of users
actually does not you know like they do
not run their own full nodes they
interact with the Bitcoin network at
best through SPV and at worst through a
trusted third party like coinbase
so what does the what does the ecosystem
have to say or do about whether or not
Forks are accepted or not accepted
yeah you don't really have a say they
kind of have a say at like a metal level
in that like users can pressure coinbase
to start following Bitcoin cash which is
a hard fork of Bitcoin they kind of have
a say at an economic level in that if
coinbase starts accepting Bitcoin cash
then the price of Bitcoin cash will go
up and so that's kind of a big deal but
in terms of like a protocol level in
terms of like accepting or rejecting
transactions they don't really have a
say because they simply cool they can't
see enough to determine whether or not
they're interested in following a fork
or not following a fork in fact it's
even worse than that there were multiple
situations where we ended up with two
chains right so an SPV wallet might
think that they received money on one
chain and they didn't receive money on
the other chain so very bad things can
happen to wallets in two SPV clients
during a fork and it's incredibly
disruptive and people who create
software on the perhaps behalf of users
so not even running SPV but like the
coin basis of the world and the
exchanges of the world they have to do a
fair amount of work to make sure that
they aren't going to lose users money
when there's a fork and the exchanges
and the coin basis of the world have
screwed this up in the past there's been
money lost there are ways to safely
design your fork so that it's less
likely that wallets will do the wrong
thing but where I think we're kind of
just figuring out how to really do that
effectively
this bulletin that tracks like yeah so
so this has gotten pretty bad because
you know Bitcoin if bitcoins like really
gonna undergo a hard-worker software
everybody's paying attention if the
theorems gonna do it everyone's paying
attention but there's so many alt coins
out there and yeah there's so much
opportunity for people to take advantage
of the disarray that happens when fork
happens so I think we're right in the
middle of trying to figure out best
practices for handling Forks and safely
from and and also giving users some way
of choosing what side of a [ __ ] that
they want because there's sort of
there's a sort of thought that
eventually there'll be economic pressure
to like for a long time people thought
that if Bitcoin hard forked one side
would win and the other side would go to
zero and now we've seen that that is
absolutely not true in fact when Bitcoin
hard for sometimes a total market cap of
one side plus the other side is bigger
than the total market cap of what
Bitcoin used to be so money is literally
created out of nowhere so hard forking
is very lucrative it literally gives
every Bitcoin user more money so if you
owned Bitcoin I don't know whether in
the past like if you owned Bitcoin a
year ago you probably have like four
other coins right now I don't know you
should go sell them or or sell the
Bitcoin and buy the other coins or
whatever you want to do but the point is
you have more money than you might have
even known that you had because someone
has done these Forks don't even like get
started about the tax consequences of
this it's very confusing
like extraordinarily confusing and
people are trying to figure out what to
do because you didn't ask for this fork
right like I as a holder Bitcoin didn't
decide that I wanted Bitcoin cash to be
a thing I didn't accept Bitcoin cash but
now the same private keys I used to
control my Bitcoin also control the same
amount of Bitcoin cash it's kind of
crazy let's talk about Forks and
practice so soft Forks in practice there
been lots of software soft works are
very useful soft works are helpful this
is a major way the people upgrade
software
and again the way that they do it is
they try to make sure 95% or some huge
majority the miners are on board and
that way it's as sort of like as non
disruptive to the ecosystem as possible
so pay to script hatch was a sophomoric
seg wit the introduction of segments was
a sophomoric an operation check sequence
verify was added as a software so it
used to be so that's kind of why they're
all these like unused ops out there in
case we want to use one of them for
something new we can do that with a soft
work okay
hard Forks in practice there's lots of
new bitcoins Bitcoin cash gold diamonds
like I said cerium went through and a
really interesting hardcourt and there
are some cryptocurrencies that actually
hard fork quite frequently for instance
I learned the Monaro hard Forks about
every six months vert coin how many hard
ports have you guys done three three
hard Forks right so there are there are
you know despite that the way that I
said that hard Forks are very disruptive
if you can get all the nodes to upgrade
it's not really a big problem right so
for crypto currencies where the nodes
are really well connected or they
auto-update or things like that hard
Forks are much less disruptive so let's
talk about the etherium hard fork for a
moment so this happened a year ago two
years ago a year ago I can't remember
when this happened two years ago I think
almost and so what happened was - you
know aetherium we haven't talked a lot
about a theorem so we becoming to
explain the theory I'm in much greater
detail but the point is the theorem had
a smart contract which had a bug in it
okay and a lot of users someone hacked
the contract and started siphoning off
ether from the contract so the etherium
team all got together and decided we're
gonna rectify this wrong now rectifying
the wrong I mean I already said it's a
hard fork but why is rectifying this
wrong a hard fork cannot a soft fork yes
because you want to change history
that's an interesting way of putting it
yeah and the way that we change history
is not by actually going back in time
and editing history unless you are
Accenture I guess which creates editable
block chains but the way that we edit
history is we add something to the
blockchain which indicates that we're
going to undo or change a rollback or
somehow create an operation that does
something that effectively undoes what
happened in the past so so the theorem
developers got together and they
originally tried to do this as a soft
fork actually so it could have been a
soft work and the way that the soft work
would have worked is that it just would
have ignored all of the transactions
that that were sort of I think that the
way that it worked was I can't remember
exactly how it worked it basically the
general idea was ignore all of the
transactions that might spend the
hackers money and so effectively give
the money or ignore the the the
transaction that's where people gave
money to the hacker what ultimately
became the hacker and which is a new
rule right now you're shrinking the set
of acceptable blocks and the problem was
they realized that if they did this as a
soft fork then they were inadvertently
creating an attack vector because people
could now spam the network and
potentially waste the resources of the
miners very challenging did you soft
farts and heart first correctly so they
decided okay you know what we're just
gonna do it as a hard fork when this
block comes about block 1 million
920,000 we are going to simply transfer
around 12 million 12 million ether from
the hackers account into this other
account this other contract which is
going to give the money back where
people can reclaim their money so
literally just hard-coded in this
transfer 85% of the hash power and
aetherium went along with it so that
means 15 percent didn't and that means
that there are two currencies now
there's a theorem and aetherium
ethic and they persist this day almost
two years later and it's about like a
when I looked this morning it was about
a thirty to one ratio between etherium
and aetherium classic yes exactly so 300
classic says we're not messing with
people's accounts like that
no no what happened happened fair and
square we are not changing history and
so when the theorem classic the hacker
has money on a theorem the hacker does
not have money yes so here they decided
there was a bug in someone smart
contract it was exploited we're gonna
get people their money back this
happened again with a different type of
smart contract in a different way a
couple months ago and they decided well
I think they're still I mean it could
still they could still decide to do it
but they so far they decided not to give
everyone's money back so there's about
90 million or something dollars worth of
ether that's locked up in these
contracts due to a bug and in the case
of the Dow they decided let's do it in
the case of this parity bug they decided
let's not do it and if you talk to the
etherium foundation people they'll talk
about governance and they'll say well
you know we feel like this made sense
for these reasons but this doesn't make
sense for these reasons but it's still
like oh it's you know it's a set of
people getting together and deciding
whether or not to give money back yeah
no it's not the etherion foundation the
Thurman foundation was not a fan of
aetherium classic it's a separate group
of people no actually it turned out
interestingly enough and this was
something that I saw at a conference
that looked into who are the
contributors to all of these different
Forks when trying to understand
governance it actually turns out that no
one from the etherium foundation works
on aetherium classic and no one who used
to work on Bitcoin works on Bitcoin cash
gold or diamond so it's all entirely new
sets of people yes he's not actually
you're talking about Gavin Andresen yeah
I don't think he actually makes commits
to Bitcoin cash yeah so I mean depends
on how you define contribute certainly
this is a really interesting example of
a hard fork in summary just to wrap up
here Forks are extremely challenging
upgrading software in decentralized
cryptocurrency x' is extremely
challenging and so the lesson that I
want you to take from this is unless you
need what a decentralized cryptocurrency
has to offer you will probably be better
off not using a decentralized
cryptocurrency they are very hard to
update they are very hard to upgrade
there are frequently bugs and so I think
that you know Forks and and the
challenges around Forks are an excellent
reason not to do this when you don't
have to right and also what's really
interesting I think is that you know
your traditional consensus systems don't
address this problem at all because your
traditional distributed consensus
systems don't have any notion of what
nodes are going to find valid or not
valid or changing the rules or validity
and so these problems really only arise
when you start to have these validity
rules that you're that you're dealing
with and you haven't
that might take one set of rules and
might nodes it might take another set of
rules
the consensus mechanism here ultimately
becomes irrelevant if you don't agree
with the validity of the blocks it
doesn't matter that a majority of hash
power said that this is the blockchain
it doesn't matter if a majority of
signers say this is the blockchain if
you don't agree that the things in that
blotching are valid you're gonna ignore
that majority be damned so it's very
different than distributed consensus
okay and so real quick last thing on
Wednesday we will have another guest
lecturer her name is Sharon Goldberg
she's a professor at Boston University
and she's worked on a lot of really
interesting things in particular
something really cool that she's worked
on is using the peer-to-peer network to
create attacks in Bitcoin and then very
recently she nor co-authors released a
paper on peer-to-peer network attacks in
the theorem and so she's gonna be here
to talk about the peer-to-peer networks
behind these things and to share some of
the research that she's done